let me fill in my passwords
i used to have a shirt in high school
that said technology must be used
to liberate the individual and i didn't
really know what it meant for years
because i didn't really think about it
but today i look back and i'm like oh
man hell yeah i like that shirt
glad i wore that shirt because how i
really feel today my name is daniel ross
today is may 3rd
2012. go through college and watch the
internet come and all these different
things and now like bitcoin
it's just a single technology built on
top of the internet but it's so
fascinating because there's so many
freaking things you can do with it
it's also just a big experiment there's
no guarantees with it
we might just all be wasting our time
concepts and ideas it's like this
crossroads of technology and philosophy
and politics and everything
and just be a part of it it's fun
it's crazy though but it's fun
um first question is what is bitcoin
[Music]
i can't tell you what bitcoin is in just
a few sentences
it takes time to understand it the same
way it took people time to understand
what the internet was
back in 1994
[Music]
and then the ring around it see that's
what i said
um yeah oh
internet is uh that massive computer
network
the one that's becoming really big now
allison
can you explain what internet is
when the internet was taking off i was
in college at virginia tech
studying computer science looking back
it's amazing to think about how much the
world was changing
hey dan ready for the game i'm just
finishing up here with my new kayaking
friends
kayaking friends on your computer yeah i
just got america online
that same type of innovation is
happening again with bitcoin
it's the smartest people in the room
that are the most excited about this so
what are they seeing
the internet changed the way the world
communicates
bitcoin changes the way money works you
can basically
put a bank in your pocket wanna buy some
secret stuff
there is now a new note that people are
starting to talk about
the bitcoin the money of the future
bitcoin was created to provide an
alternative to the banking system
we are in the midst of a serious
financial crisis and the federal
government
is responding with decisive action
[Music]
unlike most currencies bitcoins are
issued according to a set of fixed rules
the idea was to create money whose value
couldn't be manipulated by a central
authority
the government no matter how many guns
they draw cannot
change a mathematical problem they can
point their guns at two plus two but
it's always going to equal four
it's fascinating to imagine what it
means to have global
decentralized money and that's what's
[Music]
happening
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my five-year-old's birthday first round
of burgers is ready
second round's going on in the second
first round of burgers
ready first round
dan's always been an idea guy bitcoin's
the perfect combination of
how can i change the world and make it
better but how can i also be a nerd
so mostly i've just been supporting him
and this
craziness
eliza and i met in college and we've
been married for seven years
we live in pittsburgh where i'm from and
we have three boys
i've spent most of my career as a
database administrator
but for the past two years i've been
consumed with bitcoin
bitcoins come into existence through a
process called mining
[Music]
i build computers to mine for bitcoins
i'm glad that it's finally getting a
little bit cooler out
my wife won't be as angry that the
basement is so hot
i still got a bunch of mining rigs
running
right now actually right down here if
you want to go take a look
here they are
so what is bitcoin bitcoin is a
revolutionary technology that enables a
new way to send payments over the
internet
you can think of it as an open
accounting system where thousands of
computers all over the world
work together to track ownership of
digital tokens called
bitcoins when you send someone bitcoins
the transaction is broadcast to the
entire network
after it's verified it's recorded in a
public ledger called the blockchain
the blockchain contains a record of
every bitcoin transaction that has
occurred
since the system began and it's shared
and maintained on the network
so everyone keeps the books so to speak
most currencies are issued by a central
authority that controls the money supply
bitcoin is a peer-to-peer system so
there is no central authority
instead bitcoins are issued to users who
help process transactions in the network
this is known as bitcoin mining bitcoin
miners are specialized computers that do
the work required to verify and record
transactions in the blockchain
as a reward for their work the miners
earn bitcoins
and this is how new bitcoins are
released into circulation
the system is programmed so that only 21
million bitcoins will ever exist
and as time goes by the mining reward
decreases
the result is a predictable supply
that's governed by scarcity
making bitcoin somewhat like a digital
gold
it's the first currency of the internet
and everyone is free to use it
with bitcoin you can send any amount of
money to anyone
anywhere in the world as easily as
sending an email
[Music]
my brother nick is a filmmaker after
hearing me talk about bitcoin
incessantly for months
we decided to start documenting things
hey i don't think we'll need the small
camera
can't hurt no i'd rather leave it behind
i have so much equipment you mind
damn you really cramped it up huh not
that bad
geez
i was convinced that bitcoin was going
to be huge and i knew there were a lot
of others like me out there
zip my keys in my pocket so i don't
forget them later
[Music]
bitcoin was created by what's believed
to be a pseudonym
a guy named satoshi nakamoto invented an
09 by a fictitious person named
satoshi nakamoto on halloween 2008
someone using the name satoshi nakamoto
posted on a cryptography mailing list
i've been working on a new electronic
cash system that's fully peer-to-peer
with no trusted third party the post
contained a link to a white paper
in which satoshi proposed a new type of
payment system for the internet
it described a protocol that used
peer-to-peer networking proof of work
and public key cryptography
[Music]
for years computer scientists had been
experimenting with these technologies to
create digital money
but satoshi discovered a way to combine
them that had never been done before
in doing so he invented bitcoin
there are no records of nakamoto's
existence prior to the creation of
bitcoin
on his profile page he claimed to be a
34 year old man living in japan
although satoshi nakamoto is a japanese
name he wrote in perfect english when
communicating online
and went through great lengths to keep
his identity unknown
[Music]
nonetheless programmers and
cryptographers all across the world
recognized the brilliance of satoshi's
design and began collaborating with him
to further develop bitcoin
in october of 2009 the first exchange
rate was published
listing the value of 1 309 bitcoins
at one dollar bitcoins were cheap and
through the following year they
continued to trade for fractions of
ascent
in the spring of 2010 a florida man
named lazlo decided to try using his
bitcoins to purchase something
he offered 10 000 bitcoins to anyone who
would buy him pizza
a man in london accepted and placed a
long distance phone call
ordering him two pizzas from papa john's
this is generally acknowledged as the
first bitcoin transaction for a tangible
good
bitcoin was gaining momentum but in
order for it to thrive
the coins needed to be more widely
accessible
a tokyo-based exchange named mount gox
was the first on the scene to take hold
of the marketplace
and trading volume started to pick up by
november 2010
already four million bitcoins had been
mined and the exchange price briefly
spiked to 50 cents per coin
the market awoke and bitcoin was
starting to look like it might have real
potential as a currency
his name is julian assange assange and
his colleagues collect confidential
information and then make it public
the release of 250 000 state department
documents no doubt presents a serious
dilemma for this country
following a massive release of secret
u.s diplomatic cables
donations to wikileaks were blocked by
bank of america
visa mastercard paypal and western union
an article in pc world suggested that
bitcoin could be used as a workaround
to send donations to wikileaks one of
satoshi's last known posts was in
response to the article and stated
it would have been nice to get this
attention in any other context
wikileaks has kicked the hornet's nest
and the swarm is headed towards us
shortly after that satoshi disappeared
from the forums
and was never heard from again
two months later the silk road anonymous
marketplace was launched
it functioned as an online black market
for drugs and other illicit goods
and used bitcoin exclusively because it
made the money trail
nearly impossible to trace the silk road
caught the attention of new york senator
charles schumer
who was outraged and publicly called for
a crackdown on the site
heroin opium cannabis ecstasy
psychedelic stimulants
it's unbelievable throughout all this
the exchange price continued to climb
by february of 2011 bitcoin reached
parity with the us dollar
sparking an influx of new users and
speculators
by june the price had soared to a peak
of 31
before it came crashing down as the
market tanked
the mount cox exchange was hacked
further shaking the confidence of
investors and hammering the price all
the way down to the two dollar range by
october
while bitcoin enthusiasts kept hope
skeptics were quick to share their
hindsights and rants on
blogs and in news articles many thought
that the party was over
and that bitcoin was on its way out i
went online
and i bought one bitcoin last night
really
it's the future i don't know that didn't
feel real
no real's gonna change
just watch today i sent
a total of 2 700 bitcoins
to butterfly labs i purchased basically
a custom designed
bitcoin mining super computer if bitcoin
fails
[Music]
everything i have is worthless the
bitcoins i have
the computers the mining systems was all
waste of money
[Music]
but if it succeeds then
[Music]
it will have been worth it i think the
bitcoin economy was a wild west in
cyberspace that was very attractive to
hackers and scammers
over the years tens of thousands of
coins had been stolen
and 2012 proved no different users had
to be careful
if somebody steals your bitcoins there
are no consumer protections sorry
they're gone you lost your bitcoins
they're gone and you're not going to get
them back
but after months of stagnation on the
exchanges the bitcoin price was on the
rise again
the price of bitcoin today is around
seven dollars usd
uh which just had a nice little bump
this week
by the end of the year the blogging site
wordpress announced it would start
accepting bitcoin payments
and in early 2013 the discussion forum
reddit
also announced bitcoin support they were
the first major sites to incorporate
bitcoin
and these milestones signaled the
beginning of mainstream acceptance
bitcoin is the most subversive
technology on the planet
this is a system that is growing around
the entire world
so if it works if this experiment
continues to grow
it doesn't just help a few of us in this
state or in the country but it actually
helps everyone around the world
[Applause]
as the bitcoin price hovered around its
previous all-time high of 31 dollars
i visited a libertarian conference in
new hampshire it lost
20 and then it gained 20 in 20 minutes
it was it was silly libertarians are
among the earliest adopters of bitcoin
its nature is a currency that isn't
controlled by central banks makes it
attractive to this community
once i was able to kind of grok the
basic concept it was just like
this is the perfect money this is what a
bitcoin address looks like
think of this long string of characters
as an account number where your bitcoins
are stored
when you send or receive bitcoins they
are sent to these addresses
the addresses are long and hard to
remember so using a phone to scan a qr
code
is a fast and easy way to read them
another good thing to know is that
bitcoins can be broken down to eight
decimal places
this means that you can send fractions
of a bitcoin so any amount of money can
be represented
with bitcoin every transaction is public
everyone can see the amount that's being
sent without necessarily knowing the
identity of the sender
these guys even have one of the first
bitcoin atms you just
scan your qr code on your phone put in
the dollar bills
and press the button bam done perfect
you now traded your worthless piece of
paper for real currency
it's like in the fed it's like seriously
if you're going to end the fed you're
not going to defend you're not going to
change anything about the
entrance and bypass them but yeah that's
what you should do
my concern is how the governments will
react
they can't kill or stop bitcoin but they
could impede it and they could
get in the way of its development
[Music]
a few weeks later across the ocean a
financial crisis was reaching a breaking
point on the island of cyprus
cyprus is on the brink of going bust the
rest of europe has agreed to a bailout
but only if cyprus
raids people's bank accounts for quick
hard cash people trying to get money out
of the cash machines
but electronic transfers have been
stopped never did i think
that they would in a completely
unprecedented manner resort to stealing
money
from people's bank accounts the cypriots
had placed their
trust in the banking system and it had
failed them
as news of the crisis spread around the
world bitcoin believers were quick to
point it out as an example of why a
currency free from government control is
needed
there's actually bitcoin atms apparently
being set up in cyprus
all of a sudden bitcoin looks like an
attractive prospect
[Music]
while this was happening in cyprus
regulators at the us treasury weighed in
on bitcoin
the financial crimes enforcement network
known as fincen
issued its first regulatory guidance on
virtual currencies
the guidance implied that bitcoin in and
of itself was not illegal
[Music]
it was the perfect storm the situation
in cyprus suggested that bitcoin could
function as a financial safe haven
and the approving nod of u.s regulators
was a green light for investors
the market agreed and the exchange price
continued to climb
it's moving from the super super early
adopter phase to
possibly the early adopter phase bitcoin
was getting international exposure
and people were starting to pay
attention
this is actually a live updated
map of the globe and the lines represent
uh bitcoin clients basically where the
bitcoin software is running
and uh the length of the line determines
how long it's been online or how active
it's been and
every time i look at this i swear it
gets it gets more and more saturated you
can almost see an outline of the us
now uh south america you're starting to
get it uh but the big news in my opinion
is this
china you used to see one two
three maybe and this is all within the
last you know
three weeks or so that's the most i've
ever seen in china
you look down here indonesia singapore
australia new zealand
the following week it snowed in
pittsburgh i was eagerly awaiting the
delivery of two avalon asics
state-of-the-art computers with chips
specifically designed for mining
bitcoins
ifuguo is at the forefront of the new
generation of hardware
and is the first to bring them to market
everybody including myself has severely
underestimated
the mining market how big it is when
bitcoin began
a standard laptop was powerful enough to
mine hundreds of bitcoins in a matter of
days
the technology evolved rapidly over the
past couple of years
a lot of people are getting into it
we're still trying to catch up
i was on vacation with my family when
the new miners were scheduled to arrive
the price of bitcoin had rocketed to 77
so i asked some friends to wait at my
house to get them running as soon as
possible
all right
i hope this is good that was worthwhile
oh definitely
these are uh new computer parts here
excellent from china
all right uh it's not official to you
simon there we go
yeah we'll see maybe uh down the road
you guys will start accepting bitcoin
one day i bet
that's cool a matter of time good luck
all right
i notified dan and he has a little
response here
welcome to the financial renaissance
192.168.1.140.2525
192.168.1.1 that's the default gateway
my first pool is going to be
stratum.ogco.inport3333
port 80 but i can do 3333. when
everything's all said and done for at
least a little while i should be pulling
in like
10 to 12 coins a day that's gonna change
though
after another week it's gonna get
dropped down to like eight just because
the difficulty is just going through the
roof because
everybody's firing these things up so
it's always a race to stay ahead try to
be the first guy with the hardware you
know
oh i'm getting pings yep we're kicking
we are accepting shares it is live
[Music]
hey that looks like johan okay i'm going
to college because my dad minds bitcoins
so uh big day today huh big day
look at that 104 current bitcoin price
broke 100 today
um it is april fool's day
price rising so insanely high is kind of
a little bit unprecedented so i mean
it's bound to pop a little bit
maybe i don't know maybe it'll be a 225
in a week and a half
so who knows but bitcoin styles
could go up could go down
as the price passed 100 we took a trip
to visit gavin andreessen
he is known to have worked closely with
satoshi during bitcoin's early days
here's the train tracks and he did say
that there would be train tracks maybe
passing through
here we go this is gavin's house
gavin is one of the last people to
communicate with satoshi before he
disappeared
morning my brother nick
and his wife ashley hi nice to meet you
i found the place okay so good we're
very excited to be here
come in this is my humble house
that's where i work this is where i live
beautiful home
a little higher please right there's
great got it
how did you first get into bitcoin tell
us a little bit of the story of how you
got involved
i had been working at umass as a staff
programmer in the
computer science department research
group my wife's a professor at umass
i actually quit that job before going on
a six-month sabbatical in australia
i just happened to read a little blurb
online
in somebody's blog that mentioned this
bitcoin project which is an open source
attempt to do money and it caught my
interest
i basically just spent a few days
read everything i could about it looked
at the source code downloaded the source
code
thought about it and i really couldn't
convince myself
that it would not work it seemed like
satoshi had thought of everything
since then i've just been stuck down the
rabbit hole
bitcoin is open source software with
open source software
the code is publicly available anyone
can look at it and see how it runs
and they can also contribute their own
changes programmers like gavin were able
to join satoshi to work on bitcoin
simply because they were interested over
time i think satoshi
learned to trust me he could see that i
didn't
make very many stupid mistakes i never
had any
personal connection with satoshi it was
always purely business
and i think that's because he was so
worried about people finding out his
identity
i don't know why my last email to him
was telling him that i had agreed to go
visit the folks at the cia
so whether that had something to do with
him deciding
to cut off communication with me
entirely he had been pulling away
before then but the cia invited me to
come talk at the cia
and i agreed to do that
knowing it would surely spark conspiracy
theories gavin posted an announcement on
the bitcoin talk discussion forum
to head off any rumors i think accepting
their invitation and being open about
exactly what bitcoin
is will make it less likely they'll see
it as a threat
having taken on the lead developer
position since satoshi's disappearance
gavin found himself facing an increasing
number of responsibilities and public
scrutiny
your neighbors know that you're kind of
at the center of one of the most
disruptive
uh technologies i think i think they
know that i do like this wacky
bitcoin project i don't think they know
quite how big it is yet right now
bitcoin's a billion dollar project when
i started it was this tiny little
experiment
and as it gets bigger the pressure
to not screw up just gets bigger and
bigger
two weeks later the price soared past
150
and some bitcoiners woke up to find out
they were bitcoin millionaires
23 year old charlie shrem is the ceo of
a company called bit instant
bit instant was one of the first
startups in the bitcoin space
in bitcoin's infancy people had to jump
through several hoops to buy them
one of the only ways was through the
mount gox exchange but this process
required transferring money through
several intermediaries and could take
weeks charlie launched bid instant to
streamline this process
and to help people buy bitcoins quickly
yeah that's good great that's pretty
nice
yeah sure today charlie's being
photographed for an article in business
week
one of the ideas they had was like that
you're like throwing stuff up in the air
and they're gonna add bitcoins in later
on
yeah this bitcoin thing can actually
change the world but for this thing to
succeed you have to figure out a way to
get more money in and out of the
ecosystem
look out the window a bit totally yeah
and you can look
yeah that's good it does not show that
i'm super stressed out right now and
you know thousands of orders that are
being processed and i'm bugging out
trying to get the new site launched
no don't look like that i'm trying not
to but it's really hard
things have been insane
i haven't slept in days
the price is just rising so a lot of
people are putting money into it
normally charlie can get bitcoins to his
customers in about an hour
but with a recent flood of people trying
to purchase bitcoins
bit instant can't fill their orders fast
enough when i pulled up our like
customer service interface
we have close to 2 000 open tickets and
that's just from saturday
to this morning nobody was ready for
this kind of volume so
we're trying to catch up uh with the
volume and
keep everybody happy can you just sort
of describe
quickly what the last week or so has
been like for you guys
the last week or so saw our support
staff go from two people to five people
when someone offers you a seat on the
rocket you don't ask where the seat is
you just
get on the rocket further our volume has
has basically tripled in in the past two
weeks
going from a few hundred transactions a
day to now two three thousand
transactions a day you just came on
board here right yeah i did actually
today is kind of my first day oh yeah
yeah yeah how does it feel to be a part
of all this madness
um well madness yeah it's overwhelming
and uh what are you doing i'm a cfo
can you give me like a daily estimate of
how much money is moving through your
system
um it's in the in the six figures every
day
all right well thanks charlie i really
appreciate it thank you
i don't know how the government will
react to bitcoin
but i spend thousands of dollars on
lawyers every day just to make sure that
i'm not going to go to jail
it's super terrifying i mean i don't
want to go to jail
and i don't i don't want to become a
martyr either
[Music]
bitcoin was the talk of the town charlie
was in the limelight and could barely
keep up with media requests
within hours the price passed two
hundred dollars
first day of spring first day bitcoin is
over 200 the start of a new era
hi nice to meet you i'm the nice warm
loving mom
that makes him live at home because we
can't
uh we can't apart with him yet
we love him too much
[Music]
this is where it all started and this is
where it still goes down
i've been collecting money from all over
the world and it's just like something i
did way before bitcoin i've done this
since i was a kid
so it's funny that like i'm collecting
all this fee out it's not worth anything
and then all of a sudden i get into this
bitcoin thing
i realized during high school that i
could never work for anyone
i made up a term psychologically
unemployable
i started a bit instant while i was
still in my senior year of college
bitcoin currently is the largest social
economic experiment ever conducted in
the history of the world
2013 possibly 2014 will be the two years
that really make or break bitcoin
bitcoin is a first product that's
digital
but it's also scarce
i got some good news last night that
part of our licensing deals that we've
been trying to do for the past few
months are finally hopefully coming
through
we got approved to be licensed in 30 of
the 48 states in money transmission
i've been working very hard on trying to
be compliant in the legal realm
and with fincen's announcement setting
up a way for
bitcoin companies to legally exist that
really changed the whole game of bitcoin
and for us it helped us get that less
push that we needed from all the banks
and the regulators to finally hopefully
get that licensing that we need
[Music]
today charlie's meeting with a realtor
to talk about new office space
hi charlie hi i'm mitch waldman how are
you
pleasure got a minute i have 10 minutes
for you
we're we're a company with no boss
essentially everyone has their
responsibilities and just one big
executive or it's one big executive
board
one person doesn't do their job i don't
do my job these guys are all gonna yell
at me
so that's how we do it but we get things
done all right we're outgrowing this
space as you can see here
that's a good problem to have yes now
rachel said there was a great concern
about security in this space
yeah we're regulated so we can't like
share an office with another company or
they have access to us
our asset is our software our software
is processing hundreds of thousands of
dollars a day really quickly
and that's on-site here no this is on
the cloud it's all in the cloud but we
monitor we have to monitor everything
from here and debug
fix take down upload more put up more we
get a lot of high volume data
oriented very very sensitive customer
data if there were not a doorman
at the very least the space would be
designed in such a manner that there'd
be
a locked reception area if we want to
pursue like a guard at some point we
could have them in that
in that area i absolutely think it it
will be at some point
it's just a matter of time the potential
for theft is huge
it's like operating a bank essentially
that's pretty much
it it's gotcha it's basic stuff yep yep
all right any other words for me
okay are you willing to handle the task
sign me up captain
that night the price got as high as 266
dollars
every major news outlet had taken notice
bitcoin fever was at an all-time high
it is getting a lot of attention people
are fascinated by anything that makes
new highs every day for weeks on end
which bitcoin has done
in terms of the total number of the
people using the currency i'm not sure
but you can see that there's a huge
amount of fluctuation in the volume of
trading
and then the price crashed
bitcoin lost more than half of its value
in six hours
from craze to crash it's the talk of
many people in the blogger sphere
and it's certainly suffering some
growing pains the value of the virtual
currency bitcoin has plunged
it's been a crazy day today i haven't
slept in like 40 hours
your order process i don't understand
why we're still having this conversation
we've refunded your order we sent you
extra bitcoins
i don't care man when it comes to my
money i don't [ __ ] around i know man you
need your stuff
i hear you i hear you it processed your
clicks are there man
charlie what's been going on today crazy
day huh yeah i have mount gox
their whole system pretty much failed
and their whole training engine is
is broken and pretty much caused
almost has to shut down for the day
further the bitcoin price has just been
wildly swinging up and down it was down
100 today
it's gaining back up but mostly because
people can't buy and sell and they can't
withdraw and they can't deposit
because the whole thing is just it's
just a fritz so what we're trying to do
is figure out a way to mitigate orders
somewhere else for now
with mount gox stuck in a nosedive the
ripple effect is creating chaos in the
bitcoin markets
i'm trying to figure out why our orders
aren't going through
rachel am i allowed to take another
advil if i took one like an hour ago
they've been having problems ordering
anything off of you yeah
i'm getting a lot of customers emailing
saying it says executed but it's not
showing in the blockchain just got
suspended trading
really yeah order this place suspended
until 2100 what time what's 2100.
it's 9 p.m oh my god
[Music]
if you bought at 150 and
then you're at 260 and then you watch it
dip down back to 150.
do you panic so yeah absolutely i don't
know what a bitcoin is i just bought it
you see buy orders people buying and
selling at such a
wide range it doesn't make any sense
the api is just constantly failing is
that what's going on we're not getting
any orders
don't care about the price speculators
can play musical chairs
all day long for all i care i'm i'm long
i was focused on expanding my mining
operation
the only people that are going to be
shaken out by this
drop are people that are new to bitcoin
here's the avalons spinning away mining
away
and if everything goes as planned uh
we'll have 18 more of these guys in a
couple weeks bitcoin is a complicated
thing you have to spend some time
looking into it and understanding it
before you really
care and now there's droves of people
that
you know giving it more than just that
glance because the price has
gone so high and they have you know
dollar signs in their eyes like uncle
scrooge
it's so much more than that and i think
that's why the people who are mining and
people who believe in it are just kind
of holding strong
when trading resumed at malcox the price
fell even further to around 70
71 on vtce yeah bitcoin it's volatile
it's gonna be
a long time until we have stability
that's the nature of the beast
price discovery uh can be violent and
volatile and
there's gonna be a lot of people that
come and go and people that scream wolf
but at the end of the day the only thing
that really kind of stinks right now is
that
everybody's trading on one platform that
isn't doing the greatest job so
over time hopefully we'll see some more
exchanges pop up and
it's more options and people want to
keep using bitcoin
i'm sure the infrastructure will come
[Music]
[Applause]
it's just gotten ridiculously busy um
i get an email every two seconds now and
i'm pretty much you know
more email than i uh i can keep up with
jared kenna is the ceo of trade hill the
first us-based bitcoin exchange to
compete with mount cox
he's also on the list of bitcoin
millionaires
this is uh finnegan right here
jared runs trade hill out of a 41
bedroom residential hotel
called 20 mission that he also owns
[Music]
mostly rent out rooms to tech people
startup people there's a lot of
bitcoiners
i actually accept rent in bitcoin which
is great because we have a lot of
international people
[Music]
bitcoin
[Music]
came to us from the cryptogram
it came out of thin air
it saved us from those nasty dollars and
one and yen
bitcoin
[Laughter]
digital currency is gonna happen i mean
it's it's i mean it already is happening
and it will be the future whether that's
now
10 years from now 100 years from now
we're going to be using digital
currencies that don't depend on fiat
government
jarrod originally launched trade hill
about two years ago but ran into
problems with a payment processor
and was forced to shut down recently he
met ryan singer
and together they are relaunching the
exchange the business we're in is
helping people speculate right
markets are price discovery mechanisms
that's what they're for people
uh they buy they sell there's the bid
there's the ask
and the price moves and when it levels
out
that's what the market price is i can't
even count the amount of people that
have said
bitcoin is not backed by anything at
least dollars are backed by gold i've
realized that
a lot of people believe that
my grandfather he got me into investing
when i was a kid i was five years old i
could
explain a p e ratio and what a bid and
an ask was and difference between a
limit order and a market order and all
that stuff so for me i saw this as a way
that the average person could actually
take control of their finances
i just grew up pretty nerdy i don't know
like 15 like i
years old i decided i didn't want to be
a nerd anymore
which was a mistake because
now i realize it's pretty awesome
in 1999 i joined the marines i was
originally with the engineering unit
2005 i went over to afghanistan i was
mostly working with the afghan national
army
it changed me a lot as a person
i've always been interested in economics
and finance and technology and
cryptography
i was in a cryptography forum somebody i
never met who was anonymously
in this forum that i was chatting with
sent me 10 000 bitcoins
just as a way to test the system out and
see how it worked and i got them and i'm
like well that's cool but
what can i do with him and he said well
nothing yet but
if people believe it has value it will
at the time there was really only one
bitcoin exchange it was mount gox i said
we need an alternative
who cares if the technology is
decentralized and the method of transfer
is decentralized and the people are
decentralized
if all the trades are in the same
location i thought that
building another exchange that gave more
people access to bitcoin would be
a key part of bitcoin's growth the day
we launched we got a quarter million
dollars in from user deposits
and we said like oh [ __ ] this is this is
real
we're all fans of the big lebowski so
we're going to have a big lebowski party
nice
very exciting day 30 gallons of white
russian and
hallway bowling
we work hard but we party hard too okay
okay i'm good i'm good i'm not dead
yeah i'm the first one in the house
that opened the trade hill account
and it took me a long time to buy the
bitcoins because it was the moment where
everything was going really
really you know ballistics uh
bitcoins all the time and it was hard to
buy it and it took me like 10 days to
get my bitcoins
from my european bank i got my euros
over here to open a 10k
account with trade hill at the moment
where they they were 255
bitcoin and
within one hour they start plumbing down
and the same day they went down to 99
65 or something or 90 bitcoin hey stop
[Laughter]
smiling
straight hill round two we optimized for
success we launched expecting to have to
do hundreds of thousands of transactions
a second
right now we've got about 15 people in
addition to that we've got about eight
attorneys
externally a lot of people are
depositing dollars a lot of people are
passing bitcoin we're getting more
trading we're pushing that from the
business perspective
also we're talking to people who want to
do more automated trading on our
platform
get robots trading against each other
we've stress tested this and we can
handle you know
about 500 times as much volume
as mount gox was seeing so we'll see
what happens here
the interest in us is pretty crazy
just the news with bitcoin has really
kind of validated
everything now people are like oh you're
not this crazy person i'm talking about
some digital made up currency it's like
oh i've read about it in
the wall street journal in the new york
times it's real
we had an investor come in and he said
hey i really appreciate your scrappy
nature and how you're hustling
but i think it's time for you guys to
spend 30 grand a month on rent
when you have you know a billionaire
client they want to come check out your
office before they send you a
multi-million dollar wire
asking them to walk past pawn shops not
always the right feel
[Music]
so we're leaving the mission we're
driving into soma right now we're gonna
go take a look at
what may be our new office space pretty
prestigious address
one market
[Music]
right now we're trying to forge this
path and we're trying to comply with
existing laws and anticipate future laws
which is extremely expensive and
extremely difficult
is there parking here yes okay is that
included with
no of course absolutely right what is
that how much
how much does how much does that cost
from 450 to 600.
it's not terrible
that's pretty sexy
twitter was here for over a year amazon
chromes and go every single year
i have my ics i have jcpenney all the
big ones
they come over they're part of the club
sounds good we'll be here tomorrow thank
you appreciate it
thanks so much we move in tomorrow just
like just like that huh
just like that that's how we roll it's
pretty surprising that that deal just
happened so quickly what was it you just
liked the space and you said hey there's
no point waiting
we like the space we like the we don't
have the time to spend either we had all
kinds of important stuff we're working
on and you know if we spend
a week trying to find an office and he
and i put 20 hours into it or
50 hours into it it's a huge waste of
[Music]
time
[Music]
i thought they'd be in multiple bags
rather than one big one but hey
[Music]
i believe that bitcoin will do to the
banking industry what email did to the
postal service
it didn't make it irrelevant what it's
forced the post office to do is
concentrate on their strengths and less
so on their weaknesses
mike caldwell is the creator of physical
bitcoins known as cassatious coins
they are often featured in mainstream
media coverage of bitcoin
they're a novelty item collectibles that
basically act as physical carriers for
bitcoins
but they do something very important
they give bitcoin a face
come on in
sorry the kids are sleeping so i'm just
being quiet
each coin has its own bitcoin address
and the private key required to spend it
is hidden underneath the hologram
this is where you make the physical
bitcoin yeah
it's a random smattering of things but
pretty careful about the way i
manage you know the basically this is
the credential so this is the
hologram and the private keys i'm pretty
careful about those and don't keep them
here
i normally do them on this mirror
because that helps you know get the
fronts and backs
right there's so many things that
cryptography can do for us
that if the world just knew so many
social problems could be solved
cryptography can bring fairness
to elections it's too difficult for
people to understand
and someone needs to bridge the gap
right now we're using bitcoin to send
money but many believe it will
revolutionize much more
the technology behind bitcoin can be
used to build decentralized
systems with rules that can't be cheated
[Music]
now see this is my wife in my space this
is you know
awesome it is what it is the more time
goes by the more legitimate bitcoin gets
and the more proud i am to be
associated with it and now what does
your wife do
she does craft she's a lot like me we
just sit around and make things all day
it's just our obsession no i'm not a
drug dealer no i'm not a criminal
no i'm not a terrorist i believe in the
rule of law i believe in structure that
builds society i believe in families
i believe in corporations i believe in
all the essential elements
that a civilized society with law and
order
need to be able to function focal length
matters
cryptography is the basis for us being
able to implement the values we say we
believe in
this idea will never die the technology
that bitcoin
brought to the forefront the genie is
out of the bottle
[Music]
since the crash the bitcoin price has
been hovering around a hundred dollars
bitcoin seem to have weathered the storm
but there's still much controversy
surrounding the currency
the same cryptography that ensures the
user's privacy
also allows it to be used anonymously
[Music]
my father decided to retire and he had
an old failing
print shop i basically took it over and
i converted into an internet place
we're the only place in la that supports
bitcoin right now
this is my linux system here it's a
system that also mines for bitcoins
it makes about a dollar a day i just do
it for fun
i was really really into the internet
like literally in 1990 1991 1992
and i had the hardest time describing
what the internet was to people
i was tell people well it's like this
network of computers and
the network of computers can talk with
other networks of computers and then you
could exchange information
and like people would have no idea what
it was
when people ask me what bitcoin is i
have the hardest time describing what it
is
and i'd surmise it as it's basically
money it's basically an anonymous paypal
it's one of those things that you have
to use before you understand
politically i'm not a very big fan of
either the banks or federal reserve
and bitcoin allows me to get around that
one of the programs we support is a
protocol called tor
and basically what tor does is it allows
you to communicate to a website
anonymously
tor is a program that allows you to get
on a silk road
and this is silk road basically any drug
you want is available
there's a lot of weed there's a lot of
cocaine there's a lot of ecstasy
but there's also unusual drugs like if
you want some sort of anabolic steroid
you could type steroid you'll get all
the different types of steroids that are
available
silk road itself is not selling the
drugs this is basically a matchmaker
between buyer and seller
both the buyer and seller don't know
each other both the buyer and seller are
anonymous
it goes on this web of trust if you want
to
let's say by this testosterone you click
on this
he has 99.3 positive feedback for more
than 300 transactions
so even though the contracts aren't
enforceable by law
the reputation system makes it so the
system works pretty well oh there's a
fireworks section now i didn't know that
florida id 1.88 bitcoins which is
around 150 something like that
a forged auto insurance card forged
passport
there was over 9000 entries for drugs
that's a lot
i would say there's around maybe five
customers that know about it and use it
it's
it's a very small percentage of the
people that come in but the people who
do know about it specifically come here
to use it
what the customers do with the computers
is pretty much their business
another day in office if you're gonna do
drug dealing of any sort
silk road is the place to go how many
people are selling cannabis right now
it looks like 2011 people are selling
cannabis
they call me mr bitcoin i probably been
dylan dress cause i was like
17. right now i'm 26.
i think it's as a global thing when i'm
on the computer i'm doing
business with the world let's see they
have blue drains hard diesel
pineapple thai purple crush girl scout
cookies purple paste
when i first heard about it i was
laughing about it it took me a week to
just even think about this for real like
i can really make money off of internet
selling this type of stuff for me
are you sure about that
it's something i probably may buy right
here it has to look like some good kush
some of these things only take like a
day to get here with no harassment from
nobody
instead of just being on the streets
once you get the hang of it it's
actually kind of fun just looking
through different things
mr bitcoin i'm running with it i like
the name you know what i mean
i'm not gonna lie i get booty off this i
kind of like talking about this stuff
with girls like girls like that [ __ ] hot
you're not on your street and you got a
little nerd knowledge
this is great i have like a lot of
bitcoin saved up already
my business is doing good it's a fun way
of doing hustling these days like
the future brought a different way to
hustle and i like it
with so many people using bitcoin in so
many different ways
it's becoming apparent that it can't be
[Music]
ignored
today i'm visiting fincen a bureau of
the us department of the treasury
despite having released guidance on
virtual currencies there's still a lot
of uncertainty surrounding their outlook
on the future of bitcoin regulation
straight ahead in the big fishbowl
looking okay great
[Music]
i'm not going to say we're going to have
every answer for you today but the
i mean what i do want to say is that you
know we
we didn't want to shut down bitcoin um
you know we didn't want to attack
bitcoin
we think uh there's a lot of uh
social benefit to it you know i kind of
had the google alert on my computer for
bitcoin and
once a month once twice a month
something will pop up but
now it's five a day
jennifer shaskey calvary came on board
as fincens director last year
during her career she spent 15 years at
the department of justice
where she specialized in fighting money
laundering and organized crime
virtual currencies have been on my radar
for a while even prior to coming to this
position because of unfortunately the
abuse
of some of them bitcoin on the other
hand is one that
really didn't come on my radar probably
until i arrived at fincen
depending on who you speak to the
issuance of our guidance was either the
best thing that ever happened to bitcoin
or the worst thing that ever
happened to bitcoin some accusing us of
trying to kill bitcoin and others saying
that it somehow legitimized it of course
neither of those things i think is
is probably true and certainly neither
of those things was our intent
one of the clear lines is that if you're
a consumer who's using bitcoins to buy
goods and services
the guidance doesn't pertain to you
we're focused more
on the places where we think we have
risks to the u.s financial system
from money laundering and terrorist
financing and i think that might be
kind of a lot of the bitcoin community
has a little bit of a fear that
it you know bitcoin may be characterized
in a way so as to tie it
to some bad actor ruining it for
everyone when a lot of people that are
interested in bitcoin including myself
see it as just you know this technology
that we don't really don't want to see
it you know
falling into the wrong categorization of
uh with all the potential that's there
sure so the innovation around
bitcoin and and the virtual economy um
is is really one of the more interesting
aspects i think of this story the
idea that it can be used to potentially
serve the unbanked out there just to
provide some
really new services that are convenient
for consumers
the flip side of it though is that to be
a part of the financial system the u.s
financial system the global financial
system
also comes with some responsibilities
and those responsibilities include
not allowing your institution to be used
by criminals and by
terrorists
there's always been a concern that the
government might try to stamp out
bitcoin
but perhaps they see the risk of being
left behind
in may 2013 the biggest gathering to
date of bitcoin enthusiasts and
entrepreneurs
happened in san jose california we're at
bitcoin 2013
it's the inaugural conference of the
bitcoin foundation
[Music]
bitcoin is worldwide and the vast
majority of people
haven't even heard of bitcoin yet it's
more powerful than
every computer on the top 500 list
combined
it's an awfully big world an awful lot
of things could happen
really you know we've been on a roller
coaster ride and i
expect at least for the next few years
we're going to remain
on a roller coaster ride i happen to
enjoy roller coasters
i think they're fun
[Applause]
just a few weeks earlier cameron and
tyler winklevoss
known for their involvement in facebook
announced that they own a one percent
stake of all bitcoins in existence
worth around 11 million dollars
they also made a 1.5 million dollar
investment in charlie's company
bit instant we started looking seriously
at it at the end of last summer and
started purchasing
around that time i think a light bulb
just went off and
said wow like the implications of this
could be enormous if everyone in the
world can have a bitcoin address
and everyone in the world can be banked
fairly quickly
and when you consider that it's a very
powerful idea
and bitcoin can make that happen we're
going all over the world we're going to
the uk
we're going to australia we're going to
we're already in russia
we're going to south america we're
already in brazil now you can buy a
bitcoin at any of our locations
it's fun to think that satoshi might be
here too
i always wonder if somebody is someone
here somewhere is uh
yes i was planning i was planning to
hack security cameras of the
of the hotel and try to trace the
partner of walk of some person
who might be satoshi what would he do
what
talks would he be attending you know
we're seeing the bitcoin players in the
market
meeting with the venture capitalists and
they're all beginning to posture
and that's very exciting because it
means that there's going to be a lot
more infrastructure built out a lot more
money flowing into the space
and it's really going to be a big bull
market for bitcoin
one of the companies best known for
making bitcoin accessible for commerce
is atlanta-based
bitpay they're pioneers in bitcoin
and provide a service that enables
merchants to accept bitcoin payments
without dealing with its complexities
we've grown about about a factor of 10
since the beginning of the year we were
doing about half a million dollars a
month
around the turn of the year and now
we're doing about 5 million a month
this is people using bitcoins to buy
real goods and services
they're not day trading they're not
exchanging they're actually buying
things i'm confident that bitcoin is the
most important
invention in the entire history of the
world since the internet roger vera is
an investor in several early bitcoin
companies
including bitpay his passion and
enthusiasm has earned him the nickname
bitcoin jesus it is going to change
everything and all of you here in this
room
you're at the very very forefront of
[Applause]
that
lives in tokyo but travels the earth
spreading the good word of bitcoin
the last couple of days we've been
setting up a business per day to accept
bitcoin here in the bay area
today's business is going to be the
super kilpo korean supermarket
so for you like you accept credit cards
right now right your credit card
companies are charging you two or three
percent
for bitcoin you can do the same thing
but they'll only charge you one percent
you'll still get dollars in your bank
account
if you want you can choose to split some
of the payments that you receive
into bitcoins and then summon the
dollars and whatever ratio you want so
you can keep
99 in dollars and one percent of bitcoin
or 99 in bitcoin and one percent dollars
however you want you can decide that
roger's describing the service provided
by bitpay
they take the volatility of bitcoin's
price out of the equation for merchants
by immediately converting bitcoins to
dollars at the time of sale
so right now we have it set to 100
dollars so anybody that pays here with
bitcoin
they'll deposit the money into your bank
account the very next day with only a
one percent fee and i guarantee you over
the next couple weeks you'll have lots
of computer nerds
that love bitcoins will be coming in
here specifically to shop at your
supermarket
so that they can pay with bitcoin
the credit card companies just for
processing the payment
they take anywhere from 1.5 percent
to over 3 percent and then on certain
cards there's even a per transaction fee
like 20 cents
per transaction plus the percentage of
the transaction one two percent is big
we're talking about eleven twelve
thousand dollars a month on the average
that
they just take right out of our account
i honestly think that
there's a really good chance that
bitcoin will be more than a thousand
dollars by the end of the year
because everybody hears about wait i can
send money to and from anyone i want
it's impossible for anyone to freeze
your account it's impossible for anyone
to block you from sending or receiving
these bitcoins
more polish euros so you can see all
these different currency exchanges
around the world
that exchange to and from bitcoins and
you can see there's i don't know maybe
between 50 and 100 exchanges now
when i first heard about bitcoin and
started telling everybody about it if
you looked at that same page there were
less than 10.
and there's no central office that they
could raid or anything like that there's
no central it's amazing there's no
central office there's no central place
they could go to
and say take steve's bitcoins or give
c's bitcoins to kevin or do this or do
that's the owner of bitcoins
everybody that owns bitcoin yeah just
like who's the owner of gold whoever
whoever owns some gold short of shutting
down the entire internet in the entire
world
there's no way to stop bitcoin
and hit request payment and that's a qr
code for your bitcoin address so i'm
gonna scan that
so now i have your bitcoin address on my
phone i think this is two dollars
so i'm gonna send you two dollars worth
of bitcoins
there it is you just received that many
bitcoins from me directly with no fee
and if you hit the little green square
it'll show you the equivalent amount in
us dollars so you just receive two
dollars worth of bitcoins directly from
my phone to your phone and you can send
money just like that anywhere in the
world
you could have told me your bitcoin
address by email or post it on facebook
or twitter or
anywhere so i could print this and have
it at the register
yep and you can you can check right on
your phone anytime that you receive the
payment okay
thank you steve all right thank you
one of the newest standouts in the
bitcoin space is a san francisco company
named coinbase
they operate a digital wallet service
that makes it simple to buy
use and accept bitcoin i would not be
surprised at all if google square paypal
everybody is looking at adding bitcoin
in one or two years
by then we need to have 50 million
wallets if we can make this easy to use
it's going to be huge my involvement in
bitcoin is not politically motivated
yeah dude people are realizing large
capital gains
when professional investors enter the
realm the stakes definitely change
we raised five million dollars from
union square ventures fred wilson led
the round there
i think bitcoin is still actually a
little bit under the radar
i think it's moved past the stage where
people dismiss it
but i don't think that it's totally gone
mainstream either i think we're in that
middle stage right now at the end of the
conference
jared from trade hill through a party to
celebrate how far things had come
you guys are hot right now
congratulations on the raise
thank you it's good money man it's well
due
yeah i mean well hopefully it's an
advancement for the community
i am completely pro compliance like i
think like if you don't want to attach
your identity to this
i can't work with you yeah and i just
need that i mean like the libertarian
side of me is like
yeah whatever but like from a business
perspective
if people don't play by the rules
you're not gonna last yeah you're gonna
shut down you're gonna go to jail
noticeably absent from the conference
were representatives of bitcoin's
biggest exchange
mount gox just days earlier
the department of homeland security
seized more than 5 million dollars from
their u.s accounts
the seizure warrant stated that mount
cox had failed to register as a money
transmitter
putting them in violation of the new
fence and guidelines
i'm traveling to tokyo to meet mark
karpeles mount cox's reclusive ceo
[Music]
no bitcoins on here not yet
that will make this completely
unnecessary but for now it seems kind of
primitive that we're exchanging paper
for paper
and losing and losing that and someone's
taking a cut
somebody's taking me mark
and his business partner gonzaga are
french but they operate mount gox from
offices in japan
originally mount gox was in exchange for
trading cards
used in a game called magic the
gathering
mtgox stood for magic the gathering
online exchange in 2011
mark's company taban bought mount cox
and his focus has been bitcoin ever
since
one of the conditions of my visit is to
refrain from any discussion about the
dhs seizure
due to the ongoing investigation
we've arrived at mount gox this is mount
gox right here
there's no no big sign or anything no no
doesn't look like a crazy commercial
establishment despite their legal
problems
mount cox still handles more volume than
any other exchange
and is processing around six million
dollars worth of bitcoin trades every
day
we are last year on average of ten
thousand new customers a month
january it was twenty thousand then
thirty thousand sixty thousand
one hundred fifty thousand with what's
going on
it goes down but we are reaching one
hundred thousand new customers
uh for may that's a month in a month
so it was like this but still i was
after what happened i thought that a lot
of people will
go away or or don't uh don't uh create a
new icon but still 100 000 new customers
it's uh wow and here we've got the
office
for with everyone uh working
hopefully
[Music]
mount gox employs 18 people not only is
mark the ceo
he's also the cfo the lead developer and
performs
all technical operations to keep the
exchange running what's it written in
c plus is that your main is that your
main programming language
no i've got a lot of main program
languages yeah what's your favorite
programming language really depends what
i need to do like if i need to cut
something really quick and i don't care
about
performance i use php if i care it's a
bit about performance i will use c plus
plus with qt for example
but if i care a lot about performance i
will use asm
when we go in camera's down first until
we get to your servers
getting ready to go into the mad cox
data center location
your camera's down
[Music]
we were allowed to snap a few
photographs
one of the main issues we had during the
second mobile is that volume of
trading was too high compared to what
our system was
designed to support to prevent this is
we optimized a lot of the system
the old trading engine can reach a peak
speed
of 70 to 100 orders per second
with a new trading engine it can handle
about 100 million orders possible
[Music]
if mount gox's new trading engine can
really support 100 million orders per
second
it should be able to scale with the
demands of professional traders
but with complex legal problems and
increasing competition
mark's attention is pulled in many
[Music]
directions
do you work seven days a week typically
yep
it seems that you do the majority of all
the heavy lifting
literally and i need to remove your
shoes in the entrance
mark is a talented man in one of the
world's biggest cities
but maybe he should stick to computer
keyboards
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
we are here in northern new hampshire
for the porcupine freedom festival
and this is an event put on each year by
the free state project
basically it's just a bunch of crazy
anarcho-capitalists libertarian types
in the woods with freedom and families
pretty much all the vendors except
bitcoin
[Music]
tastes much better when bought with
bitcoin thanks guys salads and smoothies
i would say one third of our sales have
been in bitcoin
it's uh 20 bucks so you're paying
bitcoin uh yeah
all right last year was our first year
accepting it
we did maybe 18 transactions 20
transactions the most and now we're up
to close to 120.
this community is really one of the
largest groups of people in the us i
think that's
truly adopting bitcoin and using it as a
currency
because of what it stands for because of
what it enables
the world is seriously changing now and
it is changing
in a very interesting very radical
decentralized and in my opinion positive
direction
here it is bryce breaks the all-time
high
vitalik is only 19 years old but he has
a profound understanding of the
complexities of bitcoin
and a gift for explaining them as lead
writer for bitcoin magazine
he's been traveling the world covering
bitcoin for the past year i'm a big fan
of the
of the decentralization concept in
principle you know have
have lots of lots of uh different
societies
operating according to whatever whatever
people's own beliefs are
bitcoin has unique properties that no
other system in the world has had before
it really seems like the the only
practical way forward
as you move away from cash into your
debit cards and your credit cards you
essentially are giving up
a certain degree of your privacy without
even really knowing it
it's important to understand that
bitcoin is not automatically perfectly
anonymous
but what it does is it enables you to be
anonymous if you wish to
eric voorhees is the founder and part
owner of a hugely popular bitcoin
gambling site called satoshi dice
satoshi dice is the first of a new breed
of provably fair betting games that use
bitcoin
since all bets are public anyone can
verify the odds and payouts
at its peak satoshi dice was responsible
for more bitcoin transactions
than all other uses of bitcoin combined
it played an important role in bitcoin's
development as one of the first
applications to really test what the
bitcoin
network could handle recently eric moved
his entire operations out of the us
and into panama he started a company
called coin a pulp that lets you send
bitcoin via sms
and email i think most people
at least in america believe that when
they put
a thousand dollars into their bank the
bank is holding a thousand dollars in
its vault for them
and they don't realize that 99 of all
the dollars are digital
the fact that we have these tokens
called uh paper cash
is a is the exception to the rule people
see the cash and they think that that's
what the money is but it's all
digital and it's been that way for
decades you guys moved your business to
panama
what was the primary driver in that if
you're a us company
you have to follow the arcane us
regulations for all of your customers
around the world so if you do business
with some rural farmer in africa
you're going to need to get a social
security number you're going to need to
get all this information that washington
tells you is important
we did not want to have to apply the u.s
financial regulatory
scheme to customers in sub-saharan
africa
i don't think the developed world is
going to be where bitcoin really takes
off long-term
because our banking systems work
decently well many people around the
world
don't have any bank accounts whatsoever
ultimately those are the types of people
who will find the most value out of
bitcoin
one month later eric announced that he
had sold satoshi dice to an anonymous
investor
the price 126 315 bitcoins
worth around 11.5 million dollars
most of the new offices in the city are
in this condition
all still what's called gray not ready
no internet no electricity nothing
but we actually got one that was
finished so we moved in and we are
super excited about it you can see all
the
skyscrapers of new banks and everything
getting built up here this is a
financial center for central america so
it was
fitting that we established ourselves
here as well
still setting up the office we've been
here for two weeks we're getting walls
put in got furniture
and this is the brains of the operation
this is mr
ira he can program anything and you can
see all these books he's reading
what do we got here we got crypt
analysis
we got everyday cryptography
introduction to mathematical
cryptography
i read all these of course when i was
much younger but i was trying to catch
up with me
the bitcoin phenomenon is trying to take
control of money away from
the state and return it to individuals
it's trying to separate money and state
in the same way and for the same reasons
that it was important to separate church
and state
there's a wonderful quote from one of
the rothschilds
give me control of a nation's money and
i care not who makes its laws
so i'm trying to play my part in that
narrative
outside of the united states billions of
people don't have access to basic
banking services
bitcoin can level the playing field and
help bring developing nations into the
global economy
eventually people are going to use a
currency that is as free as the internet
because people seek out freedom wherever
they can
and just as the government can't stop
the internet and the freedom of speech
can't stop bitcoin and the freedom of
money so we're just gonna have to see
how hard they try to do it
it's scary but it's exciting because at
the other end freedom typically wins
just have to see how long it takes to
get there
[Music]
[Music]
as summer rolled on the bitcoin industry
continued to flourish
it's hard to remember the days where i
was running this thing out of my
basement
and it was like one or two people and
like bit instant was just a domain name
charlie and bit instant moved into their
new offices
i always wonder if satoshi knew that he
was going to build something that would
like foster
like companies like this where we're
actually like
company we have jobs based on something
that someone we don't know
wrote a paper on it's kind of creepy if
you think about it like i wonder if he's
like kind of watching us right now or
something
in san francisco jared and trade hill
had moved into their new space as well
it sounds funny it's not a hundred
million market anymore you know it's
grown beyond that
more professional people learning the
space and they're expecting to deal with
other professionals
but just as things were ramping up
regulators started taking a closer look
at bitcoin
so bad news for bitcoin or is it days of
glory could be ending
at least two dozen companies have been
subpoenaed by new york's department of
financial services
can't be a good thing bit instant
bitpay coinbase and winklevoss capital
were all issued subpoenas
we want to make sure that as this
enterprise grows and if it does become
a place where a lot of people are
engaging in financial transactions
that we have sufficient protections in
place with increased pressure in banking
compliance issues
bid instant was forced to suspend
[Music]
services
jared faced similar battles due to a
lack of regulation
many banks decided to cut ties with
bitcoin companies
without a u.s bank account trade hill
can't operate
and jared was forced to pull the plug
[Music]
regulation typically evolves much more
slowly than innovation
and regulations cannot keep pace with
the pace of innovation
explaining bitcoin to a bank feels like
explaining amazon.com
to barnes and noble until lawmakers
catch up
startups like trade hill and bit instant
are left out on a limb
[Music]
banks do not want to bank bitcoin
companies when you have regulation you
can comply with it when you don't have
a regulation they're not exactly sure
and if the banks aren't sure they just
default to no
new regulation takes at least one year
to
develop propose and adopt and in many
cases
it can take much longer than that
[Music]
i won't let this go i'll fight till the
end for a bitcoin
whether i have to work on the street or
sell lemonade bitcoin is going to
succeed one way or another and i'm going
to be a part of it
[Music]
over the past several months the bitcoin
mining landscape has changed
significantly
[Music]
when i started bitcoin mining was a
hobby for geeks
now it's big business in order to
continue mining and continue playing in
the game and be competitive and be
profitable
i would have to spend hundreds of
thousands of dollars on gear
the 18 miners i ordered from avalon
never arrived
and the units from butterfly labs took
over a year to ship
by the time i got them bitcoin mining
was so competitive
that i would never be able to mine back
all the coins i used to buy them
see that computer that computer makes
bitcoins and this is
all the other computers that are making
bitcoins too and it goes
straight up in the line up in the air
and that's because there's a lot of
people that are making bitcoins with
computers like that
as my new units are arriving i'm selling
them for bitcoins to try to recoup what
i can
you don't mind grabbing those other
cables i'm not coming back up okay
[Music]
i'm taking a pretty big hit but overall
the mining experience has still been
worth it
[Music]
my mining days may be over but i'm still
very involved with bitcoin
with bitcoin it's a money system where
it's backed by math
it's backed by the laws of mathematics
and by the rules of the protocol
i keep thinking that there's got to be
an easier way to just set up a secondary
protocol to trade private keys
every time i log on i see another dot on
china and i'm like this is why right now
the price is gone
the price is nearing 150 again many
attributed to the explosion of bitcoin's
popularity in china
what's happened recently is chinese
people have really come and adopted
bitcoin
as a culture as a nation chinese people
are keen to learn about
things that are on the internet things
that involve math
and science we think that china can
really contribute in the space and help
bring
bitcoin to the mainstream germany is
another part of the world where bitcoin
has found a home
it's starting to get normal if one
person a day comes in and buys a coffee
with bitcoins
people are looking for a new way of
paying and not through banks and not
with yours not with dollars something
new
the german ministry of finance even
became the first governing body to
officially classify bitcoin as private
money
i believe if we want to get some justice
back into our society
we should reduce the importance of the
banks
bitcoin is banking without banks so here
we go
the fbi today shut down what it's
calling the most sophisticated internet
site in the business of selling hard
drugs including heroin cocaine and lsd
in the sci-fi section of a san francisco
public library
undercover agents surprised a young man
quietly working on his laptop
they arrested a 29 year old software
engineer named ross albrecht
and accused him of being the mastermind
behind the silk road
people have always tied the silk road to
it media has always tied the silk road
to it as if like silk road
is bitcoin but it's not this may be a
sign that bitcoin is growing up
it's funny my friend just uh imed me and
said you know it's still crow crowd
rated and the government sees 3.6
million dollars in bitcoin
is there a way to invalidate bitcoins i
replied no
the government is now
invested in bitcoin
people are starting to finally realize
that bitcoin has nothing to do with how
people use it it's just
money it's like gold
of course not everyone thinks bitcoin is
the way of the future
bitcoin will not be able to survive or
thrive
without becoming legitimate
i don't see it having a serious place in
our financial system
they're really good reasons why we have
central banks
that have the power to put out financial
fires
by printing money i'm
worried about the technology as darth
vader once said don't put all your faith
in technology i think 10 years from now
we'll look back on this and just kind of
chuckle at
the bitcoin fad oh yeah remember
bitcoin oh yeah i remember that
it's financial freedom come on bro this
is the new world bro
others are more optimistic i think
within 10 years you're going to have a
lot of people using bitcoin
but they're not going to realize that
they're using it because it's going to
be a protocol that's embedded underneath
whatever financial service they're using
today
and by bitcoin being open source it's
what can allow all these different
mobile wallets and all these financial
technologies to all talk to each other
especially around the world whoever the
hell satoshi was
he should go down in history as one of
the greatest people or groups of people
that ever existed
this is a technology that mankind has
needed for thousands of years people
have been dealing with
monetary shenanigans since the roman
empire clipping
gold coins and finally people can escape
it
i'm cautious to try to predict the
future
we don't really know i tend to be a
technological optimist
i see the democratization of technology
as being a really positive thing
and i think that's a really powerful
force
that is really only just beginning
[Music]
not bad
[Music]
recently as the price has been floating
around 200 again
you know i have a lot of friends that
have asked me
you know are you gonna cash out some of
your bitcoins now you know the price is
really high you should you know
get some dollars out of it and i kind of
tell them
no like don't you see it
[Music]
i've met so many interesting people and
there seems to be one thing that kind of
binds a lot of them
together and that is that they're
willing to face
opposition and follow through on the
ideas that they believe in
the people who try the crazy ideas often
fail and then everybody likes to point
their fingers and laugh and say that was
such a stupid idea
but once in a while it works out i think
bitcoin is proving to be one of those
[Music]
things
the decision to bring virtual currency
within the scope of our regulatory
framework should be viewed as a positive
development for this sector
i'm here to testify because i believe
that digital currency represents one of
the most important
technical and economic innovations of
our time we are enthusiastic
about the potential of virtual
currencies and the digital economy for
social good
this latest generation of technology
which we're talking about today
takes things to a whole new level
there's a we have a
bit of a shared responsibility here in
trying to figure out how to make this
work
it is a little strange that uh bitcoin
we don't know who the creator is
and so um that often conjures up the
idea that there's some risk here that we
have not
you don't think it was al gore do you
[Laughter]
if you think a little broadly this could
again have huge huge implications
[Music]
[Music]
2013 was the year bitcoin first entered
the mainstream
and 2014 got off to a dramatic start
just as we were wrapping things up on
our film charlie shrem was arrested
after returning from a bitcoin
conference in amsterdam
he could be facing up to 30 years in
prison on charges related to his
activities at bit instant
in jfk you walk right off the plane and
you go straight to customs
about three agents in front of me and
then four agents behind me
said mr charm please come with us they
took me to an interrogating room
told me that i'm being arrested on
federal crimes money laundering
running an unlicensed money transmission
business and failing to
file suspicious activity reports the
indictment alleged that charlie had sold
bitcoins to a reseller
that operated on the silk road what
sucks is the house arrest
you know i have to pretty much be here
all the time every day can't even go
outside
unless i'm going to my lawyer's office
which is once or twice a week
i pretty much lost my freedom lost
everything that i've built over the past
year
charlie's arrest wasn't the only bad
news that rocked the community in the
new year
for months there had been rumors that
mount cox had become insolvent
and in february the site went offline
i'm not touching you i have a question
the rumors turned out to be true
mount gox had reportedly been hacked and
nearly half a billion dollars worth of
bitcoin were missing
mark was forced to step down as ceo and
mount gox went into bankruptcy
a national magazine claims to have
identified the mysterious founder of the
worldwide digital currency called
bitcoin
tonight he is speaking out but he says
he has nothing whatsoever to do with
bitcoin
why did you create bitcoin sir okay no
no questions right now i want my
freelancer
sir can we ask you about bitcoin why are
you involved in fun
okay i'm not involved in bitcoin okay
who's involved wait a minute first i'm
gonna go with this guy
i want big one oh okay
yeah this would be good oh geez i have
some honor
hey uh who's yours newsweek
claimed the creator of bitcoin had not
used a suit in him
they connected the dots to a 64 year old
japanese man living in los angeles
[Music]
named dorian prentiss satoshi nakamoto
nakamoto immediately denied the
allegations and said he'd tell a story
to the first reporter who agreed to buy
him lunch
the main reason i'm here is to clear my
name
that i have nothing to do with bitcoin
nothing to do with developing
was just an engineer doing something
else
as the media frenzy escalated newsweek's
claims
started to unravel holes in the story
led many to believe
it was nothing more than sensational
journalism
there was no conclusive evidence tying
dorian to bitcoin
amidst the uncertainty on that same day
a comment suddenly appeared on satoshi's
long dormant profile page
which read i am not dorian nakamoto
[Music]
maybe we'll never know who created
bitcoin
but the truth is it doesn't really
matter
[Music]
bitcoin belongs to everyone and the
future is
ours to build
[Music]
for the hundred thousand dollars on
market orders right now let's do it
let's go come on
come on why what's going to happen buy
100k worth of bitcoins right now
why do it i don't want to do it do it
you owe me a hundred thousand dollars do
it
i'll send you a hundred thousand no you
buy buy a hundred i can't right now i
need the floating dogs for the volume
closing bell for satoshi all right does
this look right
one npw yep yep okay and i owe you point
two
point one eight one eight this is four
bitcoin
t-shirt pleasure sir
great doing business with you i'm going
to wear your shirt proudly do it
that's one thing that's interesting
about bitcoin it's like how do you like
declare losses
you know you point to two transactions
that happen on the internet and you tell
the irs that you own that
you know oh i used to own that and i
lost the private key like
you know and then if you really do lose
it how do you write it off for taxes and
stuff
that's gonna be interesting
[Music]
[Applause]
okay guys we're gonna play a special
version of hopscotch called
bitcoin blockchain hopscotch
oh you lost all your bitcoins
who's satoshi nakamoto
i gross i'm not telling but yeah
oh do you know oh maybe not maybe
oh you know i have a bitcoin and a half
myself now
which i think probably in 10 years means
i'll be really rich
[Music]
when you think about it hard enough on a
global scale this is a net gain for
humanity